comment combattre monde heures mais on
est devant à paris hier switch avec mon
ami arnaud évolution
alors montre devant nous il ya personne
statut voilà on est les seuls on lie les
cadors à peu près de huit heures la
paris games week et ouvre à 9 heures se
faire doubler
[Musique]
paris c'est très important
oui
vasic épique dans les prix montent
parti
certains ont mal aux jambes
d'accord donc lacroix dit m
mes parents étaient très impressionnants
que la jeunesse dorée d'histoire
les sangsues que j'adore
et en 3d
la maladie
[Musique]
non
la brigade
pardi
3 2
alors tu vas
rapidement
[Musique]
gabarit
le voir
ferland viendra vécue autrement appelée
sconet d'x men et chayenne l'année
le chien y aller non j'étais d'ailleurs
pas mal
la caméra
avec mon adolescence
oui
c'est demain quarante ans et comme là
bas oui j'ai 40 ans la voix
m
nous non
village le sur la terre
il parle d'eux
nouveau
c'est ici
non
on les a tous les démons si on allait
magri gens là
merde
va pas tant
la débrouille
il est pas mal mais graphiquement
jeunes tous les deux bâtiments
on est comme moi
lewis
cet acte est rogné
maria les sens ça m'a fait partir des
toits et mes textes lui
à quoi
après après moi parce que mes
voici dans la manche cilic en fait ouais
imaginez un peu près comme les zombies
des chiens sur 94,3 com
je ne vais nulle à chier
celle qui vient d'arriver
nathan
c'est là qu'est
il va pas
[Musique]
ma seule pensée
il est maire d'istres
il avait la tête au brésil
oh
non
dans les tombes sur un groupe de vous
qui monte
prend de la cocaïne
il veut s'en aller ou non
la voix
alors
un peu avant
[Musique]
bravo
ap
j'adore
à
m
ma oui monsieur
alors
g
monsieur mairie et moi chez toi
c'est d'ailleurs
ça va chier
[Musique]
johanna lien
ok
[Musique]
g
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je t'aime
ces français est encore temps
tous savent maintenant à quoi on apprend
t-on portant pas sur la solo ça c'est 10
minutes de footing
[Musique]
je joue pas
ap hp
j'essaie montérégie
eh bien
d'amour
et ce matin c'est celle où mes patientes
et ça vaut le coup les mets
allez sensuelle
bienvenue quand c'est bon
j'ai complètement dégueulasse mais au
moins je n'ai pas piller nos 80
non plus fier de l'avoir pays
[Musique]
cros
certes on pas
saca
je ne sais pas quelle est pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
celui
[Musique]
la seule connaissance
cb
[Musique]
non
c'est un drap tendu
or
de la femme
gratuit panne sèche
ouattara
oh
[Musique]
bien
sexy
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
à
jpg je sais pas lire
c'est un jeu des photos
[Musique]
je suis
expositions livres
il
oui
c'est dit
non non non
quitter milan
on doit bien fait pas
non c'est vrai que c'est dans aucune des
parties
pendant que deux
les
[Musique]
la moyenne ce week-end
allez
non c'est plutôt longue
ouais
souviennent
l'usiné
m
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fermée
à mes yeux
il s'appelle marc ouellet
moi
moi j'ai vu l'original 15 ans
mais c'est pas grave il
q
j'ai pas précisé que tomber leurs
ennemis
ma part à vibrer
d'un style avec
hu
ça fait longtemps il l'a sorti à deux
heures
le choc
aucun des tickets de cantine
ouais
en partie sur cette maman tu adores
on y voit vraiment une affaire
oui oui je renvoie sans les femmes
habitant
une semaine
oui ça y est
c'est un legging sujet
tél
coût 10
ok
moi
il était comme ça
taylor
arrête
je voulais par jour
la maladie
il y a
c'est la vie en tête
mais hélas
oui oui oui
à 10h10 clair
et
non
m
mme lagarde
oui je crois
prenez
la côte est
m
aussi je peux le monde en rose
dormir
[Musique]
lui et moi
un peu las vegas
m
et
moi que l'acier
on avait cardon alors que vous avez qui
sert nos alors non ça
ces disques
bâle commentaire
voilà pas quand et rien que ça
c'est pas du tout
m
bientôt
genève genève bien nous
et vous genève en suisse en suisse il
non
tous
contacté par youtube
député pendant la nuit
6 puis 8
j'appelle 10 haut parleurs julien
bonjour
avec moi
merde
censure de squeeze
ben chikha boutique en vidéo non
mieux
là bas
voilà c'est génial
m
non c'est
la page
bah
mais non ue tout le monde sait ce coup
ci et là je viens de sortir de la paris
games week en compagnie de 2 go et d
autres qui sont juste derrière
au nom de dieu et je voulais vous dire
que voilà bas sachant qu'on a pris on a
pris un peu près sans volume annoncé
qu'il arrêtait sa chaîne maintenant quoi
ne croyez pas c'est votre plus beau des
bahuts 10 heures
je joue à deux et six mois toujours pâle
et de l'utiliser voilà qui en attendant
de faire le best of de la partie les
pictaves je pourrais pas faire cette
vidéo tranquille on a demandé si on est
gentil compagnon du best of de la paris
games week que vous regarderez il ya
environ 120 vidéo actuellement donc en
plus on revient au triple saut va
reprendre plein de vidéos ça est génial
et en attendant ça bah je vais vous
mettre tout de suite une vidéo on dans
les blacks et piste avec assinie me et
acide reese et du pain et des copines
que j'ai ramené mois passé mais c'est
moi qui les a ramenés et la fille de
gosses c'est ma copine on sent un peu
plus de moi là vraiment très content à
la d'accord mais félicitations même si
c'est vrai cela jeu
et puis voilà donc j'espère que ces
petits cette petite preview du vesakh
veltins arena en attendant je vous dis à
bientôt pour faire le vrai best of dans
moins deux semaines
vet'affaires une bande
comme la tombe et là maintenant je vous
dis tiens tout le monde voit lui sa luge
black eyed peas allez un petit mois de
fin un petit clic guerre alors tu
t'appelles mois de guerre roma hockey
ahl et alors tout le monde pas plus tard
pourquoi tout à l'heure à touba
l'événement c'est du pâté
[Musique]